as Democrats face off in South Carolina
the president is making a quick trip to
India a short time ago the president and
first lady toured one of the world's
grandest buildings that would be the Taj
Mahal but the main event so far was a
joint rally with India's controversial
prime minister in the world's largest
cricket stadium weecha Jiang is in
medibot India we should good morning so
how did this rally compare to Trump
Trump's rallies back here in the US oh
good morning Tony I have never seen
anything like it you know president
Trump often judges events based on their
size the bigger the better so it's
fitting that this stadium was absolutely
packed with more than 100,000 people
the rally kicked off a whirlwind trip
packed with the pageantry that the
president so loves Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi rolled out the red carpet
for President Trump as both world
leaders were surrounded by a sea of
color traditional music and dancing
the entire city of a medibot has been
transformed into a shrine to President
Trump and the mo Terra cricket stadium
shook with excitement as Modi and the
president took the stage namaste namaste
these men told us they traveled more
than seven hours by bus to hear
president Trump speak tray tensions
between the US and India have escalated
since the president took office but mr.
Trump issued this tentative promise the
Prime Minister and I could reach a
fantastic deal except that he's a very
tough negotiator mr. Trump also
announced India will buy three billion
dollars worth of US military helicopters
and got some of his loudest applause
when he talked about killing Isis leader
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi a monster known as
out Baghdady
is dead one lingering question is
whether President Trump will weigh in on
India's new immigration law which paves
the way to citizenship for people who
fled religious persecution but excludes
Muslims he and Prime Minister Modi are
scheduled to deliver joint remarks
tomorrow
Anthony we Shoshanna met about India
thanks weisia